you held on to those documents when you
knew the federal government was seeking
them and then had given you a subpoena
to return are you ready are you ready
can I talk yeah what's your answer can I
do you mind I would like for you to
answer okay it's a very simple day
that's why I asked it it's very simple
that you're a nasty person I'll tell you
what
can you answer why I'm very sorry
this event embodies the downfall of
Journalism but in more than one way
it's the downfall of Journalism in that
CNN was in way over its head and
completely unprepared structurally to
handle the uncontrollable lies flowing
out of Trump's mouth like projectile
vomiting they were unprepared to do that
that's a problem right in journalism but
also
it's the continued attacks on journalism
where when you attack the moderator
who's doing their job or trying to
your supporters cheer